Now that IT has been released on Blu-Ray,
we have access to some bonus content that
can tell us even more about this world that
Andy Muschietti has created and more about
the haunting entity that resides inside of
Pennywise.
In this video I'll break down some of the
things you may have missed in the blu-ray
bonus content and I'll be discussing another
possible ending to the movie, so be sure to
stick around for that.
This is Things You Missed.
The first bonus video is all about bringing
Pennywise to life and it includes interviews
with the kids about their experiences on set
with him.
I found myself trying to figure out Ben's
wardrobe choice, which was a t-shirt that
features African safari animals.
It's something I noticed when I did my original
Things You Missed videos when IT was in theaters,
but didn't include because I hadn't deciphered
the meaning behind it.
It wasn't until later in this documentary
that I think I finally figured it out.
"Andy has a thing with spit and drool.
Like I don't know what it is that appeals
him about spit, but there's something about
it that he loves.
So I got a lot of drool on me."
"He's very drooly and he brought this to the
character and it's a great thing because he's
like Pennywise.
He gets hungry in the presence of scared children."
OK, this makes a lot more sense now.
I went back and looked at the shirt again
and noticed that all these animals are the
prey.
Just as predators of the African savanna might
salivate over their meals, Pennywise salivates
over the fear of children.
This is also like 2 Things You Missed in one,
because everyone has their own individual
fears; Beverly has her father, Stanley has
his Bar-Mitzvah, but Eddie is a hypochondriac;
he's afraid of germs.
He's the only one that Pennywise was drooling
on, thus making him more afraid, and in turn,
making Pennywise even hungrier.
So the cycle repeats itself.
There's also a behind the scenes shot of that
children's TV show that plays on many of the
TVs in Derry, "That's right.
And you will too Henry.
Make it a wonderful day.
Kill him," where we can see essentially the
full unobstructed cast.
You'll noticed that many of the children sitting
there are look like zombies.
My theory is that these kids are some of the
past and future victims of Pennywise, and
once he devours them, they may appear on this
show.
In addition to Ben's shirt, another thing
I noticed but didn't have an answer for when
I first saw the movie, was this old-timey
tricycle in the 29 Neibolt House.
I assumed that it was just there because it
looks circus-y and maybe even as a loose reference
to The Shining.
However, in the other character video in the
bonus content we get a better look at Richie's
shirt from the end of the movie.
As I mentioned in a previous video, it reads
"Derry Bike and Cycle Shoppe" which plays
into the pattern of IT re-emerging on a cycle
of every 27 years.
The graphic on the shirt looks to be the same
tricycle from the house.
We also see a doll version of Richie in the
house, and missing posters with Richie's face
on them.
These are all clues that Richie was supposed
to die in this house, but he ends up surviving
anyway, making the other piece of text on
that shirt, "Life.
Enjoy The Ride", all the more appropriate.
The next video features Stephen King talking
about his inspirations for the book, and in
it we get a better look at the drain pipe.
In most of the scenes it's very dark, but
here you can actually make out an etching
of a stick figure holding balloons.
If only Patrick Hockstetter had seen that
before venturing into the sewer.
On to the deleted scenes.
One of the scenes takes place in Henry Bowers
room, which is a canvas to his violent tendencies.
It's filled with weapons, a road sign covered
in bullet holes and he even has a framed picture
of a gun, which I find really funny...
The next one is in Beverly's room.
In my previous IT video I talked about the
significance of Bev's Siouxsie and the Banshees
poster, and in this deleted scene, we get
to see a little bit more of her punk rock
collection, which includes a Psychedelic Furs
poster.
This is a pretty deep reference, so stick
with me here.
The Psychedelic Furs really got off the ground
when their song Pretty In Pink was featured
in the John Hughes movie with the same title.
And if you've seen that 80s classic, you know
that it stars Molly Ringwald, which ties back
into IT with this line: "Cause I want to run
toward something.
Not away."
"I'm sorry.
Who invited Molly Ringwald to the group?"
"Richie..."
"I'm just saying."
Shortly after this there is an extended scene
where the Keene girl from the pharmacy signs
Eddie's cast.
There are two things to take note of here.
We get a clear shot of her necklace, showing
her name Gretta.
That makes me think this character could be
a combination of Mr Keene's daughter and Gretta
Bowie from the book, who is a character who
bullies Beverly, as seen in the first school
scene in this movie.
The other detail was Gretta sticking her gum
on the cast at the end, which again plays
into the idea that this will really bother
Eddie because he's a hypochondriac.
Now let's talk about the last of the deleted
scenes, which was originally supposed to be
the ending of the movie.
In several of the deleted scenes there is
a subplot where Bill's family plans a vacation
to Acadia but the parents don't want to go
anymore after Georgie's death, because Georgie
was really looking forward to going there.
So in this final deleted scene they set off
on a new family vacation to a new destination
as a symbolic moving on from the Georgie cloud
that hangs over this family's head.
Then this happens.
I personally really like this ending as opposed
to it ending on Bill and Beverly's kiss.
If I were to do it, I would take away the
growling sounds to preserve the mystery of
if IT was really defeated.
Even though we know there's another movie
coming.
But let me know which ending you like better
in the comments.
I actually have one more Thing You Missed
but it does contain spoilers, so if you haven't
read the book, then you're gonna want to head
on over to another video, but please to remember
to subscribe and ring that death bell for
notifications on your way out.
But for those of you who have read the novel,
it looks like we might me getting that epic
ending in the upcoming IT Chapter 2.
Ben's room is filled with these Derry newspaper
clippings, but in the bonus features we get
a closer look at this one in particular.
This is a page out of the 1937 Derry Courier
newspaper.
This smaller article is titled, "Special Session
sets stage for Flood Control," just dropping
a small hint that Derry's strange sewer system
may be prone to flooding.
Of course, the IT mini-series did drop a similar
hint, but then no flood scene was included,
but I have a feeling we'll be seeing it this
time around.
If that's something you'd like to see, go
ahead and give this video a like.
My name is CZ and I also write horror here
on YouTube.
And of course I'll be talking about the next
IT movie as soon as the trailer comes out,
as well as many of the other big horror movies
before then.
Don't miss out on it.
You know already know what to do.
I'll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.